so I've written it the concept that I'm
using here is I'm going to start the
fight I'm going to deviate to the zone
of sanctuary but I'm going to use my leg
to spring me and to make up for the
perhaps lack of penetration do you do
it's because you stay on the striking
range you're not over committee okay so
I'm sucking him in I'm here and I'm
looking for that do so I bounce off of
that foot I know that that left hand is
coming or I should be expecting it
because I moved to this zone of
sanctuary you see that you should be
expecting it so when I move I'm looking
for that one and I'm going by him as
he's going by me I'm not we're not going
to this one whoa I'm not doing that so
we're here boom and I'm going to be
there
springy so we're passing each other so
the same thing okay so my foot has to
hit and I'm already going as he's coming
in again
[Music]
make sure you're headed the other way as
she's heading towards you not after I
BOGO that's it good Leanne Europe don't
wait for the hand go
[Music]
you can tell what his body it's gonna do
when he sets up I can't tell us that
right now so I'm moving to the back
ordering and I'm coming this way and the
left this time so I'm here okay so I'm
here see how I can transition to forward
right away
don't start walking backwards so he's
he's feeling me out so he doesn't go
flying by me like you're I'm really a
man you understand that so because if I
if I throw this out here you see I'm
fruits with him you see that so I got to
get him to keep going you almost try to
get Moscato okay so as you switch roles
right so I'm over here who seems don't
step through this punch me phone yeah so
I add you and then I'm gonna be there
right
so if you watch go ahead and step
through right here's the Edie meeting
seeing my shoulder my shoulder
relationship on the back I'm on the back
corner okay so we're gonna do the same
thing without with the cross right and I
do that look I'm not there okay
so I'm adding you room and then I'm
passing okay
so change the angles boop boop see how
I'm doing that and then if we can stop
after after you with that weapon now